what is more important implicit bias
training or tactical training in terms
of preventing shootings of unarmed
civilians implicit bias training you
think that's more important yes really
yeah if we can get an officer to
understand the culture of the community
in which they serve and go in with an
open mind and heart to the people that
they're serving they're less likely to
confront they may more readily
deescalate in a situation and learning
those values and bringing it into the
tactical experience makes tactics much
more effective are you just talking
about white officers or does this apply
equally to black officers can they have
the same type of biases against people
who look like them yes they can yeah and
and often can be a blue bias not a black
bias or a white bias but it's a blue
bias they care when they put on the
uniform where they carry a gun and again
if officers can go through implicit bias
training procedural justice training
policing in a democratic society
understand those dynamics they'll be
much more effective at promoting
reconciliation and healing in a
community I don't believe the eight
hundred thousand officers in this
country are looking for conflict I think
they're looking to really problem-solve
and build partnerships and collaboration
which is the backbone of community
policing I think those are the officers
that make a difference what you're
implying is that there is racism in the
ranks of these police departments what
I'm implying there's bias across our
culture we all have bias and so when you
walk into an environment and in a
community may have a disproportionate
amount of crime violence or drug abuse
you bring a certain bias into it if you
can recognize that bias and manage that
bias your response to that community
will be much more proactive than
reactive